you
hello everyone and Happy New Year and
yeah we have a new year last Sunday was
still last year 2018 and I covered
space-time my criticism of Peters notion
of space-time and of the fabric of
around an atom and today I'm going to
cover what we dealt with most in our
debate and that was the slit experiment
and first question comes up you know
what is the slit in fact one of the guys
mentioned that are you gonna cover the
slit experiment because that's what we
spent most of our time on and yeah I was
planning on doing that I just wanted to
cover some Matoo before I got to that
that's what we did last Sunday in the
previous Wednesday anyways what is the
slit experiment well this little
experiment is in fact I'll put your
quote by Fineman a good place to start
our introduction today he says the
following he says single photon could be
also single electron by the way double
slit experiment is a phenomenon which is
impossible absolutely impossible to
explain in any classical way and which
it has in it the heart of quantum
mechanics in reality it contains the
only mystery we cannot make the mystery
go away by explaining how it works we
will just tell you how it works they're
gonna describe they're not gonna explain
in telling you how it works we will have
told you about the basic picking
charities of quantum mechanics okay and
essentially you have an electron beam
gun and you can shoot an electron or a
photon if if you have like a laser
pointer also you could do this either
way you shoot an electron it goes
through a double slits and it creates
the interference patterns on the screen
and of course Fineman could not explain
this he was completely
just had no explanation for this to this
day there is no physical interpretation
for the slit experiment whether we use
part protons or electrons okay
and so the main question that pops up is
whether they can handle one electron at
a time like finance says of course if if
you're if you can't explain it because
you are if you're handling one electron
at a time and you produce these
interference patterns well obviously
you're gonna have very hard time you
know explaining this and you know with
particles and maybe that's what we
should have done you know maybe the one
whom people should have rejected the
particle hypothesis I mean if they
follow popper called popper Austrian
philosophy of science he said you know
if an experiment falsifies your theory
you gotta reject the theory and that's
how quantum what quantum has done they
did exactly the opposite they stayed
with a particle against all odds'
all the experiments all of them 120
percent of them falsify the particle
hypothesis there's not one okay hi I
have you know all experiments in quantum
mechanics all subatomic experiments all
of them falsified the particle
hypothesis you cannot explain a single
one with particles look at what I'm
saying okay you can explain a single one
especially all the classical experiments
you know the photoelectric effect slit
experiment polarization you name it not
one can be explained with particles you
can explain magnetism with particles you
know magnetic attraction you cannot
explain gravity with particles particles
cannot explain a single experiment that
we've ever done in the history of life
on earth and so if we are to follow
popper
you know Karl Popper says you know the
experiment falsifies your theory you got
reject your theory in this case we're
rejecting the hypothesis the assumption
that things are mediated by particles
well what's the story the story is that
instead of rejecting the particle they
incorporated it together with a wave and
they say look some experiments we will
explain with a way and some experiments
our observation will explain with a
particle and so they came up with this
wave particle neither which can explain
all experiments separately and instead
of rejecting both of them they blended
them into an unimaginable thing called
wave back that's what we have today in
quantum mechanics ok so fine done
obviously he was baffled he could not
explain the slit experiment with
particles classically in other words
with corpuscles and so Peter comes
around he brings us up in our debate our
discussion friendly discussion John I
think and he he says you know we know
for a fact that we handle one electron
at a time
we know that we're dealing with one
electron at a time and this is what he
has he this is the picture that I took
from our debate and he said we know that
there is an electron that exists at a
single point in space I can detect the
particle in a location so we can say
with a high degree of accuracy that is
particle like ok so that's his
conclusion and you can see the if you
look at that arrow that he drew the blue
arrow going downwards on the right-hand
picture I've signaled it I've
highlighted it has a single electron ok
so he's saying that the emitter the
source sends through the slit through
one of the slits a single electron and
that's what they detect at the screen or
in this case the detector ok so he's
saying he can handle one electron at a
time that's the issue ok so where does
he get this well he sent me a paper that
dealt with the
Iran of boa effect I thought that was a
little too advanced for most people out
there you know I'm not sure people
understood a lot of what he presented it
was maybe not the right place or the
right time to do that we should have
started a little simpler and and one
good place to start is Tana Mora not the
paper that he did that Peter sent me but
another paper that Tana Mora wrote or
published three years later and this is
his paper this is the demonstration of
single electron buildup of an
interference pattern by the way Tana
Mora and his group did this in 1989 this
is when they published this paper and it
was already done 13 years earlier by
Murli an Italian group murdie and his
team and for some reason they gave Tana
more of the credit but Maria really came
up with this experiment first not that I
vouch for birding by the way you know I
don't think either him or Tana Mora
handled one electron at a time that's
what I'm going to talk about today and
but this is what Peter believes he
believes that these experiments prove or
demonstrate to him or make him believe
that you know that these people handled
one electron at a time what's the
problem well right there you can see it
this is a portion of the paper and I
just put it up there for you see they
talked about coherent electron waves
from a sharp field emission tip were
sent to an electron by prism so what's
the issue the issue is that they if you
look at the picture on the left there
what you have coming from the top
downwards you have electron but you have
electron waves being emitted by a field
emission tip and I'll go over that in a
second it's known as an electron gun
okay and then it at the at the screen
they detect interference fringes which
is way at the bottom there and the pin
okay so they're saying they sent waves
and they collected a particle yeah our
particle stuff is all clearly nonsense
but it's extremely hard to debunk facts
yeah we're not gonna do politics uh let
me let me let me show you that we can
clearly and easily debunk what quantum
is proposing I'll show that today so if
you have a little patience you'll you'll
see where I'm coming from this is gonna
be all scientific okay by the way
anyways the according to Tana Morris
group they emit electron waves and then
they somehow collect single electrons on
the screen they find the interference
fringes okay and you can see the field
emission everywhere electron beam wave
of wavelength such-and-such so they're
talking about waves wavelengths and for
some reason these have a magical ability
to convert or to morph into particles
okay
so Peter thinks that because we need to
end Tana Mora by the way birdy all these
folks all the mathematical physicists
they believe that because they can
handle they see one hit at a time on
their screen or under detector that
they're handing one electron at a time
the contradiction comes with the fact
that the emitter the source is emitting
waves okay so we have waves are emitted
what the screen receives or whether the
detector receives our particles okay
that's that's the first contradiction
but we're gonna get more in depth into
this now today okay so that's where he
thats where peter gets his information
here is Tana Morra set up in a little
more detail okay
and he says electrons are emitted one by
one from the source in the electron
microscope this is a lie this is a lie
he does not emit one by one from the
source he is making an assumption that
he does
he clearly states that he's sending
waves out of the source and in fact
that's what another paper that wrote
about autonomous that analyzed on morph
paper I'm gonna put this up for a second
yeah no wrong one this is a paper Dan
analyzed Donna Maura's paper
all in favor ton amour by the way but he
says that electrons are emitted from a
sharp tungsten tip by applying a
potential difference of three to five
kilovolts that's a lot of voltage okay
keep that in mind that's going to be
important between the tip and the first
anode ring through an effect known as
field emission what the hell are they
talking about what is a field emission
well a field emission invokes a an
electron what is known as an electron
gun okay and this is an electron gun
here the definition or what they do with
an electron gun electron gun a direct
current electrostatic thermionic
electron gun is a hot cathode which is
heated to create a stream of electrons
via thermionic emission
okay so therm ionic they're gonna create
ions through heat and they're gonna emit
these these electrons that are popped
out of their atoms
that's essentially what these people are
doing okay okay so Tana Mora and here's
this set up he says he admits one
electron at a time that's not true he
does not admit them one at a time he
detects some at the detector at one at a
time he admits a waves electron waves
because in quantum electron can be a
wave as well as a particle okay
they pass through a device called an
electron by prism which
consists of two parallel plates and a
fine filament at the center see you can
see the slit there this the double slit
is formed between the two plates and the
filament that stands between them so
what the electron beam does is go around
the filament and within the plates and
that's gonna be the slit the double slit
experiment with this setup he produced
interference fringes okay and again the
source it's gonna be thermionic it's
gonna create what people call waves and
then at the detector he's gonna detect
one electron at a time or so he thinks
okay that's gonna be the issue that's
that's essentially what we're gonna be
looking at here okay so what's the
problem with this the problem here is
that we have three ways three three
explanations three physical
interpretations of what electricity is
one we can call I'm gonna call it the
classical way of generating electricity
of what is electricity the other one is
the quantum version and then the other
one is my little old rope model of what
electricity is and these three are
totally different forms of viewing
electricity of what the mechanism is if
you've had God's eyes you can see inside
a wire what would you see that that's
the issue okay okay so now let's imagine
we have a chamber okay we have a chamber
and on one hand you have gases coming
into the chamber you can introduce gases
whenever you want into this chamber on
the other you have an outlet through
which you can pump all gases and all
material that's inside the chamber you
can create a vacuum inside the chamber
that out that goes to a mechanical pump
the roughing pump as it's called also a
rotary vane pump which pumps it down to
the minus three Torr level then from
there on you can have a diffusion or a
cryo pump pump it down to say the minus
seven minus eight you can even go
further if you have the time and the
patients
but typically like you know I worked in
the minus-7 range when I work with these
pumps and so you can pump it down to
minus seven tor range that's quite a big
you know that's that's very low high
vacuum low pressure okay and that means
you've evacuated the chamber of lots of
the material that was in there lots of
the gas especially water water tends to
stick to all the surfaces you got to
heat it up evaporate it and pull it out
with pumps
that's essentially what the problem is
okay so you evacuate the chamber and but
before you evacuate it let's assume you
have the chamber normal operating
conditions in other words you have the
air that ambient area ambient
temperature everything ambient just
normal okay you're gonna run a current
from the cathode to the anode okay we're
gonna run electrons we're gonna assume
they're particles we're gonna run all
these particles from the cathode to the
end okay and so you know according to
classical mechanics you need a conductor
you need some kind of wire you're some
kind of conducting material to take that
electron all the weights from the
cathode to the anode you can't do it
through empties you know through vacuum
to total vacuum this is the setup here
I'm going to show it this is the
classical model you have all these atoms
and the atoms I just put as being still
they're not really still okay but the
point is you can send a electrons to the
Catholic to the anode even if you pump
the chamber you pump it down and as long
as you you have atoms in there you can
send them through because you need a
conductor in classical mechanics it
turns out that in quantum mechanics you
don't need a conductor or they haven't
decided whether they do or not this is
the setup for quantum mechanics you have
the electron gun which allegedly ionized
you know heats up the filament or
whatever you've got there you know the
tip
and it sends electrons over the blue are
these electrons but it doesn't need
atoms to transport them the electron
beads go through from from one from the
cathode to the anode and so the million
dollar question is if you pump down to
chamber you know like in the first case
here you have again the classical
mechanics setup you have all these atoms
there if you were to pump it down so
that you get rid of all the red balls
will you have a current flowing that's
the million-dollar question will you
will these blue dots these blue balls
these electron balls will they go from
the cathode to the anode if you get rid
of the red balls that's the question the
red balls are the atoms the blue balls
are the electrons flowing from one atom
to the next and that's the flow of
electricity accord according to
classical mechanics 19th century
classical mechanics okay quantum says
you don't quantum says that you can just
shoot them with a gun we have an
electron gun that shoots the electrons
out and they're gonna reach the anode
okay so we got a little bit of a problem
here because because if if we can do
this if we evacuate the chamber of all
gasses you would think you would think
that more current would flow because the
mean free path is increased suddenly you
know these electrons are not bumping
into atoms ambient atoms you know if you
can produce a perfect vacuum every
electron should make it to the anode
every single one this is what you would
see something like this where is it
here it is I think it's this one okay
yeah just get a make it bigger okay so
if if we remove all the gases from the
chamber every atom in there the electron
gun which is shooting electrons only the
electron should have no trouble reaching
the anode we should get higher current
that's what we should get we should the
current should increase but that is not
the case that is absolutely not the case
the case is that here we have it again
if you if so this this chamber here this
one here is with all the gases in there
okay
so the electrons are bumping into all
kinds of atoms and most of them or a lot
of them a lot of the electrons don't
make it to the anode if on the other
hand you evacuate all the atoms from the
chamber the electron gun should be
pouring you know tons of electrons from
cathode to anode it's just as simple as
that
if you pump down the chamber the current
should increase and that is not the case
the case is what we see here which is
classical mechanics that you need atoms
to conduct electricity you need a
conductor the official version today is
that you don't need a conductor or that
every material including space empty
space totally empty space ideal space
ideal vacuum all of them are simply
different levels of conductors that's
that's the party line at quantum party
line they say that everything is a
conductors just a question how much
voltage you want to put across that you
know that space okay but again if if
that is true as quantum says then if you
evacuate the chamber electrons should be
pouring in at a higher rate more of them
instead of this you would get this
I hope everybody understands that you
have more electrons flowing your current
should go up if you pump down to chamber
that is not the case and we don't need
to you know I don't need to show you
that you can run the experiment if you
want you'll find all kinds of you know
experiments that have been done I did
this every day so I don't need to prove
it to myself but if you need to do it go
ahead and look it up if you don't have
your own vacuum chamber to do it with
run a current from one plate to another
pump down the chamber current will not
go up it'll go down guaranteed okay and
let me tell you another here and I'll
give you another version of that and
that's the open circuit I guess most of
you are familiar with this you have an
open circuit and there's no light in
order to have electricity you must close
the circuit and you say well why doesn't
the why don't the electrons just go
through the air right when you open the
circuit why don't they just go through
the air and you still have light well
you can if the if the plates you know if
the two ends are close together and you
increase the voltage yeah with the
resistor obviously in there so you don't
burn the bowl yeah you can get current
rollin if you increase the voltage but
for the same voltage if you open the
circuit the electrons don't go through
air and believe me they do not go
through empty space so you know you've
got many experiments many observations
are experience that tells us that it is
not true that electrons fly through the
through space without some kind of
conductor conducting them without them
going from atom to atom even assuming we
accept the electron is a bead that
orbits the atom it doesn't happen okay
and that automatically destroys the
entire electric universe because they
believe the same thing they believe that
you know the elect a use a Bohr's
planetary model of the atom no entire
electric universe uses quantum atom and
they have these beads the electron beads
and they fly from one galaxy to the
other through empty space they call it
plasma
and plasma has this electricity flowing
through it no such thing not an empty
space electricity only goes through
conductors you need atoms that's what a
conductor is a bunch of atoms okay and
so what is my version well my version is
the rope model let's see if I can find
it here there's no electricity according
to Bill Gates okay it's uh all these
atoms they're connected they're merged
Martin asks did Peter acknowledge this
this is not the case well we didn't get
to that far because you know there were
too many questions that were raised by
by Peter he the overall discussion went
like this he sent me four papers and he
said those four papers debunked or or at
least he wasn't convinced that the rope
model could answer those four papers and
I analyzed that I think it was last
Wednesday you know the papers just dealt
with a bunch of concepts so the first
thing we had to do that's why I wanted
to get that straightened out with Peter
first I didn't you know succeed in
taking him in that direction very much
he was bent on putting his for
experiments but I wanted to get to the
basics of physics what is physics about
and I'm saying physics is about objects
well there were no objects in any of
those papers so we never got to analyze
this part that I'm showing now Martin
but again I just want you to understand
that if you have a chamber just one more
time okay and you have a current running
with normal atmospheric pressure and you
have you know a cathode and an anode
you're gonna have a current there if the
voltage is quite high okay so you run
this voltage okay you run this book now
you in fact you can you know you can
start you can put argon in there ionize
the argon which is what we used to do
and you hit you can get a current
running okay but what happens if you
pump that
the chamber so that there are no atoms
in there there will be no current
flowing quantum mechanics s the opposite
because they talk about an electron gun
they invented this thought of this in
the 1920s okay
several people worked on this and they
came up with this electron gun which
they think is an electron gun and you
have to think of it as an electron as a
gun shooting bullets that's what an
electron gun is that's what they think
they're doing
they think they're shooting bullets from
the electron gun by it's called a
thermionic emission they heat the tip
too high you know with high voltage they
to heat the tip and they think they're
emitting electrons from the atoms that's
what they think they're doing and they
think that these electrons just the
electrons are going through space to the
anode that's what they think they're
doing if that's the case if that's the
case if you pump them to chamber the
mean free path increases you should get
a higher current that is not the case
100 percent done 50 percent sure you can
talk to any person who deals with vacuum
and electricity and they'll tell you the
same thing you remove the you know
material from the system you gotta
increase the voltage if you want to arc
if you want to have you know some spark
in there otherwise there won't be
anything anything going on okay so you
can take that to the bank
electrons all by themselves do not
travel through empty space fully empty
space and just for your understanding
because there's a little more involved
here I just want this to be on the
record as well you know these are vacuum
levels
okay these are typical vacuum levels for
different different levels of vacuum
atmospheric pressure is at 760 Torr and
you can think of that as about 10 to the
19th particles per centimeter cube now
now that's a lot of particle you know
you know the what is a centimeter you
know centimeter is about half an inch
little less than half an inch so it's a
ten you bit like that and you take a
little cube of that right you get into
10 to the 19 atoms think about that
that's how small an atom is you know
hydrogen atom is 1/2 1/2 an inch from
across but y'all have an angstrom so
Diana so you're talking about something
extremely extremely small here right and
that's how much you can fit in in one
atmosphere okay 760 okay so let me get
the vacuum level again here there we go
vacuum tube you know typical tubes they
run into ten to the minus five range
that's 10 to the 12
particles per cubic centimeter
sputtering chamber the one I used 10 to
the 7th 10 to the minus 7 that should be
a minus sorry vacuum level that's poor
right and you got maybe 10 to the ninth
particles that's about a billion
particles per centimeter cube okay so so
you're talking about a lot of particles
even in a sputtering chamber that's been
pumped down to what is known as high
fact that's my back there moon the moon
has been measured 10 to the minus 8 to
10 to the minus 12 and there you still
have anywhere around 200,000 maybe
300,000 particles per cubic centimeter
interstellar space and intergalactic
space are calculated intergalactic space
or was one study that inter-cluster
medium that's what they call the
intergalactic space ICM there they came
up with a number like one particle per
cubic meter so very low density
particles and gases they they think
there's this plasma out there but the
plasma is so low density that there's
really no nothing there essentially
that's almost pure vacuum or that's
about the best vacuum you'll ever get in
the universe you know whatever
between two galaxies we never measure
that's too far away we never been that
far all we can do is say that when you
evacuate a chamber
you got gazillions of particles still in
there that's why you still have current
if you could produce a perfect vacuum
there would be no current whatsoever you
need a conductor the conductor is the
gas that you still have in the chamber
in fact that's what we did you know when
we did sputtering we brought down the
chamber to minus seven range and then we
filled it up with argon took it back to
the minus three range which is you know
less lower vacuum than minus seven range
so you take it down to low to high back
and then you bring it back up to the low
vac okay or medium back you can say
that's where sputtering occurred that's
where you can do something with it
otherwise you can't do anything with it
and okay so the bottom line is that this
is the model for the Rope hypothesis we
have all these electron shells they're
merged and again I'm simplifying here
because I've got an S shell here only
think of that as a hydrogen atom
obviously you know you're you're dealing
with molecules not with individual atoms
this is just to show you the you know
the mechanism that's all I want to show
here and what they're doing the atoms
are truly you have what I call a
serpentine all these atoms are
interconnected forming that whole red
line we're going to call it a serpentine
the serpentine twirls in place think of
it as a drill bit turning in place I
think I showed you last that last time
we had quantum mechanics which does it
with cannonballs this is the quantum
mechanical way they make holes in the
wall by shooting electrons across space
okay and you know I'm suggesting that
what's really going on is this that we
have a drill bit twirling in place so we
have a different mechanism for
electricity and the Rope model is the
the rope that the drobik twirling in
place that's what you see there okay so
that's electricity according to the rope
hypothesis let's see I've got here we
get a better or a different version of
that and why I show this version is that
you can see the electron shells are
merged but they swing around the threads
the threads that have come loose because
of the high speed in which the electrons
are twirling they pull the threads out
or they push them out and the threads
swing around the serpentine there and
that's gonna be the magnetic field as
you can see electricity goes into your
eyes downwards and the electric field
the magnetic field is at 90 degrees to
the flow of electricity that explains
why when you take a circuit you know
when you take two wires they either
attract or repel each other being
parallel to each other depending on
which way the current is flowing because
it's those magnetic lines physical lines
which are interfering with each other
and I showed that in a different video
I'm not gonna go over that right now
just summarizing there so what is the
slip version but is the same as mad
perhaps not for this episode but isn't
electricity I guess under there are each
the same as electricity the same as
magnetism no no they're different Martin
just in smaller scale shells must spin
clockwise or counterclockwise to
transport current well we'll take you
you gotta take a rain check on that you
that's a can of worms that you raise
there but I can go over that in a future
presentation to preach your lecture let
me continue with this because I do want
to cover a couple things here some
ground I hope we understand that there's
three mechanisms that are on the table
for what
electricity is one is the electron bead
goes from atom to atom you need a
conductor conductor we're talking about
atoms the other one is the electron gun
which quantum invented they said you
know we can shoot electrons without any
atoms to serve as highway ok so just the
electron beads it's like the cars flying
you know there's no highway and the cars
just go through air I guess right and
then the other one is the drill bit
twirling in place you know so those are
the three mechanisms on the table for
electricity the one you can reject for
sure 100% sure is the quantum one why
because no electron beats fly through
space why do we why can we prove that to
ourselves or be convinced of that it's
because if you take electricity inside a
chamber and you pump it down the
electricity should increase because the
mean free path has increased that's not
the case it's exactly the opposite you
remove material current will go down you
need to increase the voltage that's
that's what happens okay okay so I hope
that is clear that's the first part and
then what's the second part well the
second part had to do with me get it
organized here a little bit so that I
didn't talk a little more sense we have
what was it oh I just want to show ya
one more thing here before I leave this
subject and that's this is the rope
version of the slit experiment using
electricity okay I used the same setup
that connemara had and what you see
there I've just superimposed on that the
serpentines electron shells which are
again these are molecules here using
them as atoms but I just want you to
understand the mechanism you can see the
magnetic field there's every
then it's just going around the atoms
the serpentines and what what we're
actually doing is simply sending one row
of not sending but they're totally in
place but what we're doing is having the
atoms twirl in place around the filament
and that's being controlled by both the
filament and the plates which are either
grounded or voltages applied to them so
you can control the shape of the curve
around the filament with those plates
and what we're saying is essentially we
have matter there and what's happening
is that the electron serpentines these
atoms these electron shells which are
merged one into the other they're all
twirling in place and you can govern
that you can manipulate them any way you
want what I suggested many years ago now
for some people to do who has the
equipment is to put this entire system
under vacuum if you put it under vacuum
[Music]
you know you're going to be removing
electrons and I'm saying putting it
under vacuum but don't increase the
voltage just you know do whatever you
were doing get your current get your
what is it your fringe is but now just
pump the chamber down and see if the if
if the current increases or decreases
that's all you got to do and then you'll
you'll know for sure whether you know
whether quantum is correct or not
whether quantum is on the right track as
far as its explanation of the slit
experiment anyways we had a dialogue
with Peter and and the issue was this
fabric thing he said the atom has this
fabric around it which prevents the
electron from flying away because the
issue was the following if if we're
gonna talk about the
drumbeats being detected one at a time
you must begin by showing me your Adam
because apparently you're proposing a
planetary model of the item in other
words you're saying there's a little
bead somewhere around the nucleus that's
what you're saying that's why you can
move that bead manipulate it one at a
time as Tana Mora says and shoot it
against this screen or against the
detector so I asked them well what keeps
the electron to the nucleus what what
keeps the electron from flying away and
he said well there's a fabric and I said
what what is this fabric you said this
fabric is have you heard of a voltage I
said yeah I heard of a field also is
that what you're referring to another
word for field no a field is not the
same as a voltage and I'm saying no no
is a field the same as a fabric and he
says no a voltage would be one
description of what's going on
associated with this fabric so you know
and he used different words he said well
it's a fabric of space he's in the
fabric of potential he used all these
words none of them wear a fabric of
cloth and so the question was you know
is there such a thing as a fabric of
voltage or his voltage and voltage be
considered some kind of fabric and you
know I hate to startle you but no one to
this day knows what voltage is okay no
one no one has any idea no one can tell
you what voltage is in physical terms
what is a voltage you look up the word
and you'll find the following definition
if I can find it here here's the
definition voltage electric potential
difference Electric Pressure or electric
tension is the difference in electric
potential between two points okay and
they usually simulate it with water if
you got lots of water on top you got a
little wire around the bottom well there
you have a difference in potential and
they call that a voltage that's the
analogy they give they have no other way
of explaining voltage they just say look
this is positive five and the other one
is negative five well you know I did
voltage a couple months back now I'm
gonna bring up a couple of those
pictures and the first well let's go
step by step first thing we have to
realize because this is related is that
electrons spiral along a wire okay when
you have current flowing the electrons
are known to spiral it's known as
Fleming rule if you have a magnetic
field and the electrons are going
through that magnetic field the
electrons will spiral and that's what
you have along a wire okay
that's the first picture now let's look
up the dynamic version of this so that
you can get an idea how electrons move
are long a wire that's essentially how
they move they moved like in a circular
or spiraling way okay whether they move
forward or not that's a separate issue
but they do go around okay that's how
that's how they move okay and that's
been verified by many experiments and
that's what we call knowledge okay okay
so so here is my set up for the battery
remember a couple months ago I talked
about the battery here's a battery this
is typical one of the original batteries
of LED battery and you have on the right
hand side the negative pole and the
electrons electricity that's what you're
seeing there are spiraling I hope I did
a good job there or as best as I could
you have to think of those electrons are
spiraling around that green wire okay
from the negative pole to the positive
pole okay and the question is you know
why did they spiral and what does this
have to do with voltage what is voltage
is it just a difference in potential you
know and what is that what do you mean a
difference in potential so what we do is
we show the the what is it the rope
hypothesis version of this and all the
are interconnected and what you have is
that on the right hand side you have
clockwise motion of the serpentine that
goes all the way around and it had
better end up as counter clockwise at
the other end and that's what voltage is
Mother Nature doesn't understand -
minuses and pluses 5 volts and minus 5
votes she doesn't understand that stuff
she never went to college she
understands clockwise and
counterclockwise that's baby stuff
that's kindergarten stuff we all
understand that that's mechanical that's
physics and so what we have is the
entire serpentine going around all these
atoms are interconnected they're really
molecules but here I'm just simulating
with atoms because it's easier to
explain what we're saying is that
voltage is simply clockwise and on one
end and counter clockwise on the other
that's all voltage is okay you give it a
stimulus and that's what you get okay so
why is this pertinent to what we're
showing here to get myself in there
again it's pertinent because of the
following an atom does not look like a
bead going around a nucleus and atom
looks like this which is what chemistry
has been using for hundreds of years
there well I'd say several decades maybe
a hundred years this is what the
chemists used to do atom to atom bomb
bonding hybridization and so on these
are n this is what an atom really looks
like you have the s shells the P shells
you have merging shells and the quantum
folks they treat all these as orbitals
they say oh these are orbitals and so
you looked up and say well what is an
orbital well an orbital is a region
where you can find the electron B okay
that's fine up to that point but the
problem comes next when they say that
that the orbitals merge from two atoms
and they form a molecule
what do you mean New York I thought the
orbit
was a region and what is a region of
what you know what is this is this a
membrane and yes under the rope model
this is a main bring what we're looking
at is the actual atom we're looking at
balloons that's what an atom is
according to the rope model so we're
consistent with chemistry we're a very
consistent we're saying these are not
orbitals these are balloons and what
Schrodinger's equation does is give you
the shape of the balloons that's what
his equation does quantum on the other
hand says well what showing yours
equation does is give you a point you
know it's somewhere in the in the
orbital and yeah because that's what an
orbital is it's a balloon so they're
looking at points all along the balloon
that's what they're doing and so
Schrodinger's equation is is a way of
drawing point by point the P orbitals
the S orbitals D orbitals and so on then
your drawing orbitals okay so if that's
the case and obviously there is no
electron bead that can go you know from
from a source to the detector or to the
screen and again you gotta think about
this because if if the electron is a
bead as they say why would it come out
as a as a wave and you got to keep in
mind that both the photon and the
electron they travel the quantum says
this okay this is not me okay
it travels as a wave it's only becomes a
particle upon contact at a mission and
at reception but in between it travels
as a wave and so you know when these
people say that they emitted a an
electron bead no they what's traveling
is a wave and then they bring their
magic one at the last moment they
converted into a bead into little dot a
little particle the corpuscle and now
they say see what hit the wall or the
detector is a corpuscle
but that's magic they haven't explained
what they need to explain is the
conversion what was the mechanism of
or fiend wave into particle that's what
we want to know because if you have an
explanation for that fine then we've got
it made but of course that's magic
because the wave is extended extends
throughout the universe it's a field and
a field extends throughout the universe
particle is concentrated it's on the
point how did this thing that covers the
entire universe suddenly you know
collapse as they say the wavefunction
collapse how did it collapse and become
a particle a little point a little
corpus a vibrating field or localized
portion of the field they can't explain
it that's the issue and so they said you
know that's why people like finances you
know we don't understand don't try to
understand it just we'll just describe
it to you we can't explain it that's the
issue the issues they cannot explain
with a rope model we can't explain it
because it is a physical mechanics plane
how mother nature runs her universe and
we have to do it with particles with
well you know with something solid with
an up with objects that's what we have
to do it with okay so what can we
conclude from all this by the way here's
a blow-up of Peters atoms so that people
don't accuse me of putting words in his
mouth he does think of an electron as a
bead that's tied to the nucleus and the
question where does the gray stuff that
separates them that's what we want to
know we want to know what that gray
stuff is and that's the question that no
one in quantum can answer okay and so
Peter what he did was he took his rag
and he says look you know this is what
it is it's a rag and on the right side
you see that area I circle there
irregular shape there these lines that
he drew he says well you know it's this
potential potential of wood and it's a
potential voltage yes or that the
voltage is associated with a potential
which in turn he he says it's a rag or
it's a fabric so he turns the word
potential into the word fabric to give
it some physicality that's all he did
and that's cheaty there is no physical
object in quantum mechanics he should
know that
so he should not try to explain from a
physical standpoint what keeps the
electron from flying away because
quantum does not have an explanation for
this and in order to have an explanation
they need an object and they don't have
one so they don't know what separates
the electron beat from the new nucleus
and that's the only question as to that
well one of the most important questions
that quantum mechanics has to answer
ok so summarizing here let's look at the
conclusions we get from all this see if
I can put this up here ok these are the
conclusions conclusions the electron gun
misleads mathematicians to believe that
electron beads fly through vacuum never
happened never will an ideal vacuum zero
particles right is a perfect insulator
you can't send electron beads through
there assuming electrons were beads
electricity requires a conductor and a
conductor means atoms if electricity
consists of a flow of electron beads the
proponent must illustrate the atom ok
otherwise you know we don't know where
you got this bead the bead obviously is
something that is orbiting or somewhere
around the nucleus ok so please draw
your atoms so that we know what you're
talking about
if the theorist illustrates the electron
as an orbiting beam he needs to
illustrate the medium that prevents the
bead from flying spontaneously out of
the adamant that fabric that Peter
talked about he needs to identify that
unambiguously ok no no excuses there the
otherwise he's not doing physics
otherwise he's doing extra Syst neither
potential no voltage qualifies as a
fabric or as a physical medium voltage
is not a physical object voltage is a
concept you need to tell me what voltage
is how it's produced physically in order
to talk about you know physical
interpretation otherwise you don't have
a physical interpretation voltage is
defined as a difference in potential
that's where the voltage is therefore
mathematical physics has no physical
interpretation for voltage okay because
voltage is a concept it's just
means a difference in potential and you
cannot say that's a fabric and if
voltage is not a fabric and neither is
potential a fabric then don't use the
word fabric because all you're trying to
do is insert it there without any
justification
therefore it is irrational to state that
a concept such as voltage binds the
electron bead to the nucleus of the atom
and physically prevents its departure
you cannot use voltage as a physical
object claims that lab technicians have
handled one electron at a time are
assumptions claims that the slit
experiment was performed by sending one
electron at a time cannot be regarded as
scientific until the theorists in
illustrate their version of the atom you
need to show me what your atom looks
like to see if the bead is there and if
the bead is there just tell me how it
stays close to the nucleus before you
emit it okay that's the first step if
you can't do that you don't have a
theory
we won't here we will listen to your
theory you got to illustrate that and
I'll ask for the quantum physical
interpretation of the slit experiment is
unscientific because the electron is
regarded to be a wave at admission and a
particle at impact
quantum does not explain the mechanism
of this magical conversion okay and once
again the main point I want to make get
across today and it's these pictures
these gifs that I've got here and that's
where is it I can find it electricity
according to corner - well let's go with
the classical first here's the one for
classical mechanics okay this is the one
for classical mechanics you need atoms
to convey electricity you can't do it
without atoms if you pump the chamber
down suppose the the electrons go with
your atoms you won't have a current
flowing if you remove all every single
one of those atoms out of there
okay quantum says something different
says that if you heat an electron gun
all these electron beats go across and
they don't need atoms to go through if
that were the case then if we pump the
chamber down we should
get more electron beads going across we
should have a higher current that is
clearly not the case
okay that's falsified completely by
experiment if we're gonna use the word
falsification so that's that's a lie
never happened never will you cannot
send electrons through the air through
vacuum total that perfect vacuum and
then what do we propose instead we
propose if I can find it here
[Music]
Oh get it here somewhere
[Music]
got so many of these you know give me a
minute here oh here it is
and here's the version of the Rope model
that's that you do need atoms you do
need a conductor but the conductor
itself is electricity all the molecules
are spinning in place in situ and they
could be air molecules it could be water
molecules inside the system if you pump
the chamber down you will not have
current so classical mechanics and the
Rope model agree they diss both disagree
with quantum mechanics which says you
can have electrons without atoms you
know it doesn't it doesn't occur
electrons don't flow all by themselves
especially through the vacuum okay so
those are the main three ones and that's
the main point I wanted to get across
today so Peter has to justify that the
detector detected one electron at a time
that is not true that's his
interpretation it's no there's no
justification for it first of all
because he needs to draw his atom first
and second because even if he could draw
the atom and say look the electron beat
is held by God to the
nucleus okay or by angels fine so the
electron beetus held by angels now we
heat the Angels up and they release the
electron being fine if that were the
case then we have that scenario inside
the chamber if you have electricity
flowing from one plate to another you
pump down the chamber electricity should
increase that is clearly not the case
that also debunks quantum mechanics and
we should follow copper in this case and
say yeah if the experiment shows that
your theory is incorrect I are we gotta
get rid of the theory and not force fit
it you know in there at all costs okay
so once again happy New Year to everyone
and this is this is how we start the
year hopefully I'll see you what is it
this coming Sunday and we'll cover some
of the issues that people brought up
okay was he on Sunday see you then bye
bye